brett michaels good to see you sir it is
great to see you thank you for having me
and this is this is awesome yeah thanks
brother i love it i'd love to have you
here as well i mean so much to talk to
you about
uh your auto scrapography right okay um
and you're nothing but a good vibe tour
your incredible uh charitable works
and then uh i don't know if you can
include in the charitable works as well
the tweet that you sent out of our phone
lines um
that have since lit up since you it's a
good start
i'm like thank you you're a giver
you're a giver you're a giver um and
there's so many people that are
literally um uh can't wait to chat with
you so i appreciate it and then also
thank you for
your support in uh my charitable work
with saint jude i noticed that you've
you've done that and you've been
tweeting about it so i really appreciate
that you're very welcome and what you do
is incredible i mean going on besides
the show and everything you do for all
of us that are mega sports fan and
everyone in here on your team
but uh i just said with st jude's it's
such a place close to my heart and
watching what you do and we'll just
continue uh to do it together i
appreciate that man because your your
your charitable works uh definitely you
focus on childhood cancers i know that
right absolutely i mean oh my gosh is
there um
is it so let's just throw that out there
right now uh the life rocks foundation
how do people get involved with what you
do very simple light bronx foundation is
a complete non-profit um it is a dollar
in dollar out foundation and what it did
is i started it and i thank my mom and
dad for this they were incredible
my mom and dad were very
uh integral as a as i got uh diagnosed
with uh diabetes at the age of six
and so um instead of waiting around they
were so
immediately said look you're gonna have
to work really hard you know i mean you
have to have this unbroken fighting
spirit and you can do whatever you want
which sports was a huge part of that and
music they were like the the perfect
combination right and so my mom and dad
formed a diabetic youth camp in
harrisburg pennsylvania no one had ever
heard of this before and all of a sudden
all these other kids i was the only kid
in my entire school that had was
diabetic doing the five and six shots a
day yeah you know so i was just you know
again but i never
uh we never took a victim mentality our
mentality was to this is the card you
were dealt and you you just have to
learn to deal with this if you want to
go play football baseball music ride you
know i love motocross you know still to
this day love riding sure so from that
we got the life rocks foundation and
what it was from day one when i could
finally uh
uh
finally get out there and and with music
uh finally break we started the life
rocks foundation and it's a boutique
foundation and we go to everything
from you know saint jude's to we just
did a big concert for 50 legs uh in
florida with a lot of athletes coming
down
and it just what it is for me
it it not only is a great thing to be
able to give back but it it feels
amazing to have an
a badass concert a great purpose people
having a great time and everyone the
fans incredible and their charitable
donations we match it and we make sure
it goes out immediately that's a life
rocks foundation for our terrestrial
radio audience that was uh brett
michaels who is here in studio right
here on the rich eisen show thrilled to
have you here especially since it's your
birthday it is my birthday birthday
thank you very much
thank you thank you it is i heard like
hey uh brett michaels is coming in and
it's his birthday i'm like really i mean
so
thank you i appreciate that you've even
considered i was number one
consideration i uh i want to say this we
when we were talking about i said what a
great way to start my morning i had this
whole idea with the coffee cup which i
left somewhere i think it's right over
there
if that is possible bring it over liz
this is and show mug any time you want
to and i made sure it was double-sided
so we didn't miss
[Laughter]
did i not yes i want to say this was the
uh i love this this was the touristy
yeah
if you don't mind i would love that no
it's a birthday gift was it in your bag
you gave us the best birthday gift the
whole place was lit up back there it was
amazing fantastic yep um so before we
get to the phone lines that are all lit
because there's so many fans who want to
talk to you
so uh what do you think of the steelers
signing of mitchell trubisky michaels
this is what i think as a die hard
growing up in pittsburgh die hard
smash mouth pittsburgh steeler football
fan i'm going to tell you what i think
i think he's going to do a great job
okay i think he's a great quarterback
and i think when he came into the bears
you know and correct me if i'm wrong in
this i think again it takes the entire
team it takes a village
and if i'm not blaming the line but if
things aren't working right
you're gonna have a tough time being a
great quarterback if things are falling
apart on you right but as a quarterback
you got to be a leader step up and and
know what you want to fix you got to say
listen i need to get in there and be
really proactive work with people
inspire them to want to block for you
you know what i mean it's if you don't
inspire the team and i think for us i'm
a believer and i think he is going to be
a tremendous quarterback for our team i
know a lot there's people out there
different opinions i can only give you
mine i'm also a guy that has to believe
that it's going to take it to that next
level and i think sometimes you get the
right chemistry the right people if
tomlin stays
mike's incredible i know there's offers
out there and i don't know i just i
never understand why steeler fans want
some want him gone i think he is uh
truly one of the best in the business he
always has been the teams have never had
a losing record with him and it's
because they don't give up he refuses to
allow them to they buy in what he sells
i truly love that guy um
so yeah i mean obviously
it is uh a post big ben world and we'll
see how it goes who was your your
steeler growing up who's that guy for
you when i grew up and and before i say
yeah i was going to say first of all is
it mike tomlin's birthday yeah my time
the same day as me today happy birthday
we're the odds of march
i see you back there
okay
so let me say this i i'm a believer in
mike and meeting mike me and my
daughters went out on the field we're
doing the terrible towels we do we bring
them on yeah brought out all the
veterans mike always comes up super nice
his eyes are driven he's focused i think
mike's great
and he inspires the players oh yeah
happy birthday mike there you go for
sure i know so who was your who's your
guy growing up my guy my guy growing up
that inspired me and i remember the
exact moment was jack lambert so as a
kid i'll never forget this i get a
little emotional about it i was up there
taking a beating from all my cowboy
friends and fans right cowboys are a
great team you know and we're there in
the super bowl we're having a rough go
rory misses the kick right and i believe
it was harris comes up smacking him on
the head making kind of kind of the bust
in his balls
and uh and jack turned around
and his he grabbed him threw him on the
ground it was you can watch this over
and over he was pissed off
and that energy
willed the steelers that willed them to
win that his and his legs i love it you
know my dad used to say look at his legs
his determination he was just he was
just giving it he was out there his legs
were going there was no one getting by
them
and then again the steelers team they
always say they weren't always great
they were just great when they had to be
and they were they were great they
turned it on swann making that catch and
stallworth and the whole team incredible
i personally i i might be wrong i've
changed my life
and usually i like to i like to have
information buttoned up but i kind of
heard a story one time that jack lambert
was a roadie for
for the rolling stones or something like
that i i have a feeling like he i for
some reason that will you look that up
chris i'm and it led to somebody else's
opportunity it's kind of crazy i don't
know what that's all about but that
means i have to know that story now this
is like
my music history mystery i might be
totally wrong on that front but
um i just love your your fandom and
obviously your your passion for
everything that you do uh let's take
some phone lines speaking of passion
before we start yes i got one thing i
want to throw this out there okay sure
rich what about my buddy family friend
okay of our family matt corral okay ole
miss yeah
they i'm telling you i know um i know
trubisky's in i get it and i hope i said
that properly correct yes okay the
i know he's in but i'm telling you
matt corral is a this kid i've seen him
grow up play all over the place in
southern cal he has got for whatever my
two cents are worth he's got that heart
of a lion his guys would get hurt on the
field he'd run out carry him off the
field team player quarterback yeah he
has a a
unbroken fighting spirit now again for
those who may not be familiar your
connection to matt corral is family okay
yeah no other other i'm just saying this
but you know sometimes you can have a
family friend that's good it's something
but you're going
nfl that's you're top and top right top
of the league right i mean you're the
best of the best and but he's got it and
you know
someone out there if it isn't the
steelers is going to be very lucky
and uh yeah he didn't work out at the
combine because of you know his ankle
injury that he suffered because he
wanted to play that ball game so can we
discuss that right please here this is
huge topic for me you go you go through
it's such a strange thing because we're
in such a a tough time and i know they
have all the words for it now
these athletes play with their team
and then they get to this moment
where
they're asking do you know their agents
there's big money so in defense of them
they're going i don't want to get hurt
my last game and on the other side of
that coin is if i'm a team player i'm
going i'm going out like a lion i'm
going out fighting i want to play with
ole miss you know
and go to win and then you have an ankle
injury but i i think you know i saw the
rehab he's going to be amazing and
it's such a catch you know please weigh
in on this because it's such a catch-22
of
us as as viewers right
you're watching them and i i want to see
them play
and and he was like there's no way i'm
not going out there to play so there's a
party here that has to absolutely admire
that that would be his fight
on on a team i say it's his prerogative
to play or not to play i don't have a
problem with a kid who's like you know
what i don't want to play in this game
because it's not the national
championship and if as long as he and
his teammates are cool with it you know
uh i'm fine with it as well uh i mean if
you've seen players who get hurt
significantly in those bowl games and
you they've got to think about their
long-term future and i know right and i
don't view it as the
red flag that he's going to be a bad
professional or a bad teammate in the
future because they have not they've
decided to opt out i i have no problem
with that and again i was my heart was
in my throat when i saw
corral on those crutches and it just was
again i mean you must have been beside
yourself yes i was watching i saw the
tackle and i was like that and and
here's the thing what i say is 1 000
agree with you that you're looking at
these
fact to go you know in the the first
round of the draft you're looking at
your future big money your family
there's a lot of stuff so i wouldn't be
mad i just think what i was saying is if
they choose to play knowing that the
risk is high of an injury but if they
choose to play what i was trying to say
is that heart i call it the heart of a
lion the fact that he cared about his
teammates and he didn't want to let them
down
ag again
you know then there's the injury but i
was just saying i think whoever whoever
picks up matt is for last part of this
he is such a he is such a fierce fighter
chip on the shoulder which i love as
long as that energy
and anger isn't bitterness but rather
focused towards winning the game if you
can focus that do you text tomlin or
colbert and say 20th overall
guys
i said i want to make some moves here
mike it's your birthday it's my birthday
yeah
i'm just throwing it out there sure just
throw it out there and see how it flies
brett michael's here on the rich eisen
show you were you were kind enough to uh
tweet out that you're coming here
um excited and then i appreciate that
you said that and we're excited to have
you here especially again on your
birthday my gosh uh phone lines are lit
people cannot be more excited to talk to
you and um let's take some calls
absolutely all right don in pennsylvania
oh you're first in
first up you are on the rich eisen show
live with brett michaels what's up don
first off happy birthday solo
mechanicsburg boy thank you very much
here's to the berg both pittsburgh and
mechanicsburg to us wildcats
[Laughter]
how are you doing today
i'm doing all right bro all right all
right i took a little bit of wind out of
my sails i wanted to get your opinion on
trubisky but i've got it but what other
moves like uh
getting the coach from miami
um what do you think we need to do with
our secondary
anything else we want from our steelers
but yeah here's what i think again i'm
going to go back to mike you know and
again i know there's always rumors out
there i know his contract is still a few
more years uh here's my real feeling and
and you know i'm i i believe they say
black and gold but black and yellow
right
and and and i say this i think
that the choice of quarterback is first
of all we got to believe i think if he's
given the right
line if tomlin comes in if mike's
continuing on i think mike is going to
set that up we're going to believe in
that and we're going to make that rock
and i think again
in the secondary i know
that
it's hard to say this because i'm a guy
that firmly believes we have a great
team i just think there's got to be a
little bit of chemistry and i want to
say this i've said it on every show the
one thing i always beg and i know i
don't ever want to pretend to be a head
coach in the nfl but
play to win i hate when they go to big
zone
eat up the clock
you might as well just walk the ball 15
or 20 yards every play
down to the other side i say
take the risk and play
not time clock management don't do it
that's that's my two cents again it's
just an opinion
but i'm a go play to win guy go when you
start doing that i'm like well why don't
we just march them down the field 20
yards on every play
and then it puts a secondary in a bad
position don in pennsylvania thank you
for the cause
there we go my two cents again
are they going to hook me off the show
no
bro thanks for coming you're fired what
are you talking about
it's your birthday that's right you
can't be me
rory in santa ana california you are on
the rich eisen show with brett michaels
what's up rory
hey
brett happy birthday first of all rory
thank you very much uh
i've got uh cece developed one of my
neighbors out here i love you know my
you know i love my cece deville
cece
and he just he just hit me up right
before i walked on the show uh he texted
me and hit me up i'm going to give him a
call when we're done
yeah he wants to you know hey he's been
running for years trust me out here you
know waiting for this tour i think you
know absolutely
he's a great guy it's kind of funny a
lot of people out here thought he's a
homeless guy running for a long time
the way he dressed
you know so uh somebody finally said
that's cc to build yeah it is isn't it
do you many times i've heard i i want to
say how many times i've heard that we'll
be out on the road and cece throws on
he's an adamant runner now right got his
life together rocking it but he'll put
on this stuff that you you're not quite
sure what's happening but whatever it's
doing it's working you know what i mean
although we do
it's incredible
all right rory yeah you're a great guy
thank you thank you i'll see you on the
stadium tour this summer my friend there
you go nothing but a vibe tour currently
on tour uh in advance of that summer
tour yep uh for more dates you visit
brettmichaels.com
uh the summer tour begins when uh the
summer tour i believe kicks off in mid
to early june and we're in atlanta
because of the uh obviously the pandemic
over the last few years we announced it
in 20 yeah uh then 21.
and now 22 and i'm like this is i said
if i have to drive the trucks myself i
don't know what's going on i'm not
kidding
i'll load it in i'll help and they're
going to put me to it i know what's
going to happen that's the first venue
you ever played on very first venue was
if i remember correctly was the paradise
bar and grill in mechanicsburg
pennsylvania where we helped move the
pool table out of the way and i dressed
in the bathroom public bathroom not
large public bathroom and uh it was a
hell of a show it was great
what's the biggest venue you played then
biggest venue um would be well the
stadiums but we then
when it hits it was amazing and on cat
dragged in uh we got to play texas
stadium with uh with aerosmith and uh
and in boston and we walked out there
and if people want to see it it's the i
won't forget you video from poison
83 000 people and for the first three
songs
i didn't even know where i was at i was
just i'm like what i my eyes couldn't
focus on everything
the amount of people all partying it was
everything you thought
a rock and roll concert was and it was
incredible when all of a sudden paul
stanley from kiss walked down on stage
and started playing guitar and i was
like this is a good day right here is
that the stadium with the hole in the
roof is what you're talking about yeah
texas stadium
cotton bowl i think
okay the old cotton ball oh okay yeah it
was rich it was an incredible i remember
walking down there and stephen tyler's
like give me the thumbs up and i'm
thinking i just saw him a year ago and i
was in double z
at the back of the arena
with the less than reputable tickets you
know what i mean possibly bootleg and uh
i'm not making that up i'm like he's
really it says horse race on it but they
let me in and you know and uh i've got
in the back of the arena i'm thinking
he's giving me the thumbs up and then
all of a sudden uh you know here's paul
stanley out on stage it's on the video
he just walked out and started playing
guitar with us and it was it was a good
day in my life well if i'm not mistaken
uh paul stanley's real last name is
eisen it is one thousand percent correct
no relationship i want to bring it up no
it's okay i want to bring it up and i
don't i've never i never have i don't
ask never never had rosh hashanah dinner
with uh cousin paul
never did
you know we're putting that together
guys
we could do that we could do that that
is so cool that you have those moments
where you just have the goosebumps where
you're just like okay this is the
coolest freaking thing it is and it i
got him today
it's a you go back and think about it
and i'm one of those guys i for whatever
it is i i hope that
i'm grateful for the chance to be here
the chance to do that
and just given a chance you know that
was all i asked when i was a kid i'm
like look just like nfl anything you got
to pay your dues you got to put your
time and you got to that sweat equity
but given a chance and i think they're
so
that that's what i want so many people
to hopefully take from this my kids you
know that listen it it doesn't get
handed to you and you got to earn it and
even even guys that are going to be
drafted that's just a foot in the door
barely a foot in the door at the big
table
and then you gotta then you've got to go
rock their world take the opportunity
and go crush it crush it that's it uh
let's go to angie in minnesota uh you
are on the rich eisen show with brett
michaels what's up angie hello angie
happy birthday brad hey thank you so
much how are you angie i'm good how are
you i'm doing awesome it's great to hear
your voice
can't wait to see you in minneapolis
it's going to be awesome we're there
this weekend and uh we're coming up this
weekend and then back in the summer on
the stadium tour uh and so was it
confusing i'm out on the solo nothing
but a good vibe tour and then we segue
into the stadium tour uh throughout the
entire summer into the fall it's going
to be great and
minneapolis one of my favorite ever
memories i just want to say this play in
when i believe it was called the met uh
the original arena oh my god that it's
one of our videos that we use footage
from and it was an absolute insane party
many good times in minneapolis
yay well i can't wait to see you in in
the stadium i can't wait thank you so
much
angie appreciate it uh speaking of angie
do we have confirmation about the jack
lambert uh rolling stone story i
actually researched
no disrespect to my guy over there but
out of all three guys that i would want
researching it he would probably be the
last to do that you would not want to be
you would not want to ask that like
accuracy is not your forte no no this is
the music i turn to this man any day of
the week absolutely but in terms of
googling and researching
you obviously nick saban
and well they were hired it was nick
saban actually told the story that they
were hired when they were playing
football
as
basically security for the stones at a
concert
and he told it on a show that it was him
and jack lambert they actually worked a
stone's concert together nick saban and
jack lambert well actually that's kind
of different from the story i'm reading
right now
wait wait wait wait wait so sorry right
but you know what this i like the inner
the entertainment value because now my
mind's going like music history's
greatest mysteries i say all of us do
this
we love an altoona i love it 8-1-4 in
the 4-1-2
4-1-2 so apparently nick saban i didn't
realize this played college football at
kent state with jack lambert okay so one
night
saban and a linebacker named bob bender
they were chosen to work security for
the rolling stones and somebody tried to
throw something at mick jagger this guy
slapped it out of his hand mick jagger
called him and he hired him as his
bodyguard right so this guy apparently
according to sabin stops coming to
practice
he's now i'm a roadie i'm a security guy
bob bender bender so i'm going on tour
with the stones bro
out so that's how lambert got it that's
how
the coach is like well we've got to have
a middle linebacker that's the most
important thing they played a 4-3 in
those days so he moved jack lambert to
middle linebacker and as saban said the
guy made all-american and the rest was
because
was to kick off the beginning right i
mean it was pretty much the story all
right good i just want to make sure
so did saban tell that story on the show
how the hell did i know that
uh
coaching the nick saban show yeah
right i heard that story that jack
lambert got an opportunity i knew
somebody got an opportunity so
i love it very good that's amazing you
never know who's you you never know
who's what football history you brett
michaels could make by having the right
roadie on the tour i'm just telling you
right now and you think about that
moments in life right did have an impact
think about that had that guy not had
mike drop on mount i'm going on tour
with the stones
we wouldn't have jack lambert and i
wouldn't have my story it's a long line
of things
it's a
ripple in the pond of steeler life it is
a ripple in the pond what is that tuna
rocks okay
that's a new drop
right there we'll be playing that for a
long time
you've got a lot of fans back there
brett said
i'm happy to hear that all right uh
let's just take one more um
i feel so bad that i'm gonna be leaving
somebody on the floor here but there's
so many people who want to speak to you
andy mighty moet uh let's go to
uh roxy in vero beach florida what's up
roxy you're playing the rich eisen show
i wow i actually got through true story
i opened my twitter to wish brett a
happy birthday saw his tweet and figured
what the hell so happy birthday there
you go thank you very much
let's ripple into it and vero beach by
the way i gotta say this
as i've traveled quite a bit
vero beach one of my favorite beaches
just south of melbourne and sebastian
inlet right yes nice last time you were
here though it was cold it would you
remember okay you ready for this sure
the day before they got jake owen at the
concert right out it was a you and and
we both have sold a
ridiculous amount of tickets the day
before 75 or 80 degrees i'm not making
this up at night my night
hit below freezing i walked on stage in
my t-shirt i go what happened during the
day i was i'm like i'm sun tanning this
is an awesome day the next thing i know
i walk out we come out and i knew it was
cold but there was no way they're like
do you guys want to cancel this thing
it's about to snow
and we're like we're not canceling we're
going we're pennsylvania tough right and
we're going out there and it was a great
concert
it was awesome we wound up getting your
guitar afterwards and coming back and
meeting you it was great too it was
great to meet you and you know where
that we matched that money when we did
the life rocks auction which by the way
just go to brettmichaels.com if you're
if you're interested in the life rocks
foundation
i have i've donated
that's so cool
in fact we i had my daughter with me the
last time i had met you i was still
living up in new york you played the
white plains civic center i remember
back in 1988 my daughter was six weeks
old well when we saw you in vero she was
standing right by my side and she met
you as well
see that's the ripple the years and
great great generations i want to thank
you not only for you and your daughter
but your donation to life rocks we match
that and you saw the kids that night
that were there um that were with all
the uh first responders the kids that
had had all the um
the burns and severely burned it was
incredible yeah we that's where it all
went well roxy thanks for the call
appreciate it i'm glad you got through
thank you roxy there you go very good
we're about to take some more phone
calls with you brett michaels uh chris
you could take a look at the phone lines
as well
how many times and we've been on the air
here this is our eighth year now right
you're right yeah you're right how many
times you look down we've looked down
thankfully you can knock on wood many
times and saw all of our phone lines lit
that that is that is an occurrence that
we are we're proud of but have you ever
seen a jessica jesse bridget izzy uh is
he jada and nikki has that ever happened
in the history of the rich eisen show
you've got a certain demographic that
we don't usually feature so regularly
phone line lit you gotta let's keep also
as soon as
the line goes
off another one it immediately fills
yeah that's it well that's because they
love you guys and i just happen to be
the only nicki that calls us is the one
who tells us to stop calling right
[Laughter]
from swingers
thank you what happened to that girl you
should call her
i will take her call right now nikki in
vermont you're on the rich eisen show
what's up nikki
hi there this nicki will not tell you to
not call me okay
that's why we love this nikki
this is a different nikki
i'm all grown stuff okay
sweet sexy nicky
sweet sexy nikki this is about to turn a
different uh a different sport right now
we took all from dallas a sweet sexy al
from dallas next time
i love sweet sexy nikki
we don't get a lot of that around here
thank you very much thank you for the
awesome birthday wishes i can't wait to
see you i know we were just up at the
arena in mohegan sun that was incredible
i know sweet sexy nicki
we'll get into that story later
so i couldn't give you a hug
i know they had a lot of uh still which
is you know right safe for everybody
that a lot of the restrictions yet but
mohegan's sun was it's such an amazing
arena if you remember uh sweet sexy
nikki the the picture we got of uh of
all of us for the rolling stone uh the
big rolling stone covering article
i said we need to do it right here we
went out on the thrust i got down on my
knees and like this is what makes the
world rock the fans right here this is
what keeps the rock and we'll go round
that was great and it's what's funny is
my husband never goes to a concert
right so he actually went with me to
mohegan instead of my best friend
crystal
so i told him the reason why there was
no meet and greets is because he wasn't
allowed to actually meet my boyfriend
[Music]
by the way tell your husband i hope he
had a great time i hope yeah thanks for
the call nikki thanks for the call nikki
love you guys here uh for a few more
minutes on the rich eisen show let's
take let's try and sneak in one more
phone call here on the program we'll go
to jessie in ohio what's up jesse
hi brett um first of all i just want to
tell you happy birthday
thank you thank you
you're very welcome um i know you meet
hundreds of fans all the time so i'm
sure you don't remember me but i met you
a few years back at the honeywell center
in wabash indiana yeah abs i know it
very well
yeah um so
and then a couple years ago you called a
radio station and i happened to know the
dj so he asked you to record a sound
bite for me and you said that i rock
your world
you also rock my world
this is making my this making best
birthday ever right here this is a good
day and thank you for saying that and
make sure you know we're we're going to
be playing a whole bunch right there in
that area make sure i get to see you
again when we come back through town not
just the stadium tour but also going to
be through there a few times uh
throughout the early spring uh leading
into the stadium tournament nothing but
a good vibe tour and i can't wait to see
you and thank you for spending uh this
time with me early in my birthday thanks
jesse appreciate it i'm going to see you
in cleveland in july so
cleveland
cleveland rocks it is going to be a
great day i've heard that one before
michaels.com uh is where you can check
all that out um let's sneak in uh one
more uh jada in tampa florida what's up
oh my goodness i can't believe i'm
actually on here talking to you uh i
don't want to make it about me though i
want to say happy birthday and speaking
of birthdays i have to be probably your
youngest yet biggest fan for my 21st
birthday happening in july i'm actually
having a rock of love themed 21st
birthday party
that is awesome um first of all thank
you second of all the rock of love mega
birthday themed party is going to be
incredible and we're going to get some
information if you hang we're going to
send you something awesome from the
actual rock of love
mike and then i'm going to bring the
whole but we're putting this band back
together we may come and play there
can't promise that okay oh i would
absolutely die i mean i'm looking at all
these different like cover bands because
i know you're going to be super busy and
i actually missed you when you came to
uh you know tampa in late february and i
was so sad about it but um regardless of
what happens again super big fan the
21st birthday i don't think any of my
friends are going to really know what's
going on but i don't know they will know
trust me they they
i promise you and you know what before
you go mark make sure they hold so we
can send them something it's not
who's got a finger that's very fast be
very careful put it back easy
take it easy pick up the phone take it
here we go every now and then
people off camera that aren't over there
michael's auto scrapography you can get
it at
shopbrettmichaels.com for more dates
visit brettmichaels.com on the nothing
but a vibe tour unbroken his new song is
available right now the life rocks
foundation please go and donate right
there happy birthday sir thank you very
much this is an incredible night thank
you for having me of course and um you
know i've got 90 seconds to go uh
there's going to be big daddy points at
home for me and i understand all the
accomplishments you have had in your
career but for me to tell my children
that i hung out with the banana from the
math center
absolutely
huge we're going to get them something
i've got
mark
not mike mark mark two bananas for the
kids
three three bananas for three minutes
like orange whips
three bananas
that's why you're the best dad ever
i'm running i'm running can i run a
close second on that i'm a fairly good
people we're
they also thought it was a little unfair
they're like you're a singer you know
what i mean
i know but you know can i tell you
something i had to sing through that
banana hole
it was my eye and mouth it was real
[Laughter]
is a miracle all right
and on that note
happy birthday you want to come back
tomorrow
every day
[Laughter]
and you can see why brett's such a start
just the way
he's hold on
brett michael's on twitter michael's
official on instagram happy birthday
thank you very much what a great day
hopefully first of many times you'll be
back absolutely a couple more minutes
with brett because brett you're like
let's all take a picture we didn't have
enough time in the commercial breaks i
figured another couple i'm happy
i'm loving it you know and so uh yeah
the mass singer my kids cannot get
enough of that show and they always
think that they think like um
you know it could be like the queen of
england in there they think it's like
beyonce they think it's it's lebron
james and i'm like kids
if i i've made them a bet
i will give them if it's
a mass comes off and it's any member of
the obama family right or beyonce right
a crisp 100 bill from dad done i'm
positive it was beyonce
hey that's who i was going up against at
least in my mind
i said this is some tough competition oh
my god did any did any of the panelists
guess it was you did they nail her they
nailed it the first date because of some
kind of move i made and that's what
happens on the show i'm saying it's such
a such a fun show and they take it
seriously i didn't know who that tony
was there i didn't know any of this
stuff and uh but it is when i tell you
it is the hottest sweatiest
outfit when i didn't know i was going to
be a human banana
this far into my career and then it
happened my dream had come true
nuts to texas stadium
nuts
nuts to the summer stadium tour
it was a lot of fun i loved it and the
producers were great but you didn't know
who anybody you had no idea who that was
nobody of course take that very very
seriously they do know that yep i know
that
well it's great to see you here again
thank you and to everybody who is on
hold that we couldn't get to we
apologize but uh you'll be back and
we'll do this again absolutely and to
everybody for calling in thank you and
all the fans for the i call them family
now but three generations even four
generations of incredible fans and uh it
i can't thank him enough and i can't
thank you all everybody in here for
rocking our world check out again
brettmichaels.com for the nothing but a
good vibe tour and then the summer tour
uh after all of that and then shop
bretmich.com for his audio scrapography
and so much more hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here